بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اخي صاحب السمو الملكيه الامير محمد بن
سلمان
ولي العهد رئيس مجلس الوزراء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه رئيس القمه
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو معالي من
العام لجامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو
الغيط اصحاب المعالي والسعاده السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
اسمحوا لي في مستهل كلمتي ان اعرب عن خالص
الشكر والتقدير للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه بقياده اخي خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي عهده صاحب
السمو الملكيه الامير محمد بن سلمان على
الاستضافه الكريمه لهذه القمه وعلى ما
حضينا به من كرم الضيافه وحسن الاستقبال
والرفاده وجهودهم والوفاده وجهودهم
المشهوده من من اجل وحده الامه والدفاع عن
مصالحها
وتطلعاتها في التنميه والاستقرار والسلام
كما اتوجه بالشكر والتقدير الى الاشقاء في
الجزائر قياده وحكومه وشعبا على ما بدلوه
من جهد خلال رئاستهم للدوره السابقه في
مرحله عصيبه من تاريخ امتنا
واغتنمو الفرصه ايضا لاعرب عن تقديرنا
الكبير لجهود الامين العام لجامعه الدول
للجامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
ومساعديه وفريق عمله في مؤازره ومناصره
قضيه شعبنا وحقه في استعاده مؤسسات الدوله
وانهاء الانقلاب وانهاء انقلاب الميليشيات
الحوثيه المدعومه من النظام الايراني وهو
امتنان موصول لكم ايها الاشقاء على
مواقفكم الثابته من القضيه اليمنيه وفي
المقدمه دول تحالف دعم الشرعيه بقياده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودوله الامارات
العربيه المتحده التي سطرت على ارضنا
واحده من اع ظم الملاحم العربيه في ردع
التهديدات المحدقه بالامه خلال العصر
الحديث وهو شكرا ايضا للاشقاء في مصر
والاردن الذين فتحوا ابواب بلدانهم
لاستقبال مئات الالاف من ابناء شعبنا
الباحثين عن ملاذ امن من بطش الميليشيات
وتسهيل فرص حصولهم على العلاج والتعليم
والعيش الكريم
اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو اصحاب
المعالي تنعقد هذه القمه في وقت ما يزال
فيه شعبنا يعاني ويلات الحرب التي اشعلتها
الميليشيات الحوثيه منذ انقلابها على
التوافق الوطني في سبتمبر 2014 بدعم من
النظام الايراني المستميت من اجل استكمال
مشروعه التدميري في المنطقه مع استمرار
انقسام منظومتنا العربيه وعجزها عن
الاستجابه للازمات والنزاعات المسلحه التي
تهدد بانهيار الدوله الوطنيه
وتجريفها لصالح المشاريع الخارجيه
التوسعيه الدخيله على مجتمعنا وهويتنا
العربيه وتراثنا للحضاري والاجتماعي وانني
امن ان نستلهم من صمود شعوبنا وتضحياتها
الجسيمه في مقاومه تلك المشاريع لاحداث
التحول المنشود واستثمار اجتماعاتنا هذه
في استعاده المبادره والتوافق
السياسات المشتركه التي تستجيب لاراده
الامه وتعلي مصالحها وتضعها فوق كل اعتبار
لذلك نحن على ثقه بان تمثل قمه جده في ارض
الحرمين المباركه منعطفا هاما لاقرار
السبل الكفيل تحدياتها باداره واراده
عربيه خالصه اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه
والسموم اصحاب المعالي والسعاده بعد نحو
سبع اشهر على انعقاد قمه الجزائر وما نزال
وما تزال تلك الامان التي حملناها اليكم
بتجديد الهدنه تواجه تعنتا من قبل
الميليشيات الحوثيه دون اقتراث لمعاناه
الملايين من مواطنين في الداخل والخارج
وها نحن اليوم من جديد نترقب ثمار المساعي
الحديثه التي يقودها الاشقاء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وسلطنه عمان لاحياء ذات
الهدنه التي التزم نا باستمرارها من طرف
واحد حرصا على انهاء معاناه شعبنا وتفويت
اي فرصه للمليشيات في العوده الى التصعيد
الشامل
وبدلا من ابداء حسن النوايا تجاه
المبادرات الحكوميه تواصل تلك الميليشيات
للشهر الثامن على التوالي منعا وصول السفن
والناقلات التجاريه الى موانئنا سعيا منها
لسحق المكاسب المحققه في المحافظات
المحرره بما في ذلك انتظام دفع مرواتب
الموظفين واعاقه فرص توسيعها لتشمل
الموظفين في المناطق الخاضعه بالقوه
لسيطره الميليشيات كما تستمر تلك
الميليشيات في تهديداتها لدول الجوار
والسلم والامن الدوليين بنشر مزيد من
الطائرات الايرانيه المسيره والالغام
البحريه والقوارب المفخخه والانتهاكات
الجسيمه لحقوق الانسان التي يرويها لنا
كقصص من الجحيم ابناؤنا الذين تنفسوا هواء
الحريه في عمليات تبادل للمحتجزين بعد
سنوات من التعذيب والاخفاء القسري
[موسيقى]
واحد سته اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسموم
لقد رحمنا بحذر في مجلس القياده الرئاسي
والحكومه بالاتفاق بين اشقائنا في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وايران على عمل ان يؤدي
ذلك الى مرحله جديده من العلاقات
الايجابيه في المنطقه التي تصب في مصلحه
الشعب الايراني ووقف مغامرات نظامه
المدمره والتوقف عن التدخل في شؤوننا
الداخليه وانني يقترن هذه الفرصه لاشود
بجهود الدول الاعظه والامانه العامه
لجامعه الدول العربيه التي افضت الى
استهداف مشاركه الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه
في اجتماعات مجلس الجامعه على طريق حل
الازمه السوريه وفقا للمبدا الخطوه مقابل
الخطوه وبما يضمن وحده وسلامه البلد
الشقيق والسعاده دوره التاريخي في العمل
العربي المشترك
بجهود المملكه العربيه السعوديه والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي تكللت بتوقيع
الاشقاء في السودان على اعلان مبادئ
لتامين الاعمال الانسانيه وحمايه المدنيين
تمهيدا لمحادثات بناء تعيد للبلد الوفي مع
شعبنا الاستقرار والسلام والتنميه كما
تؤكد الجمهوريه اليمنيه التزامها الكامل
بدعم حق الشعب الفلسطيني في اقامته
المستقله وعاصمه القدس الشريف الشرقيه
وفقا للمبادره السلام العربيه والقرارات
والتشريعات الدوليه
وتدين التصعيد الاسرائيلي المستمر
واجراءاته الاستيطانيه التي تقوض من فرص
السلام من فرص السلام والامن الاقليمي
والدولي اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
اصحاب المعالي والسعاده اسمحوا لي في
الختام ان اعرب عن خالص التمنياتي بالنجاح
لهذه القمه بقياده اخي خادم الحرمين
الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز وولي
عهده صاحب السمو الملكي الامير محمد بن
سلمان التي نثقوا بانها ستمثل نقله اضافيه
لمسار العرب العمل العربي المشترك وتوحيد
الياته في دعم جهود الاشقاء والاصدقاء
للسعاده مؤسسات الدوله اليمنيه وانهاء
الانقلاب والانتصارا لصبري وتضحيات شعبنا
وحقه في الحريه والكرامه الانسانيه والامن
والاستقرار والرخاء والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات